no money that you have is not the issue
it doesn't actually take money to make
money it takes courage to make money it
takes contacts to make money money is a
contact sport I need to make contact
with people okay it's not about skills
it's not about education it's not about
personality it's about context the more
contacts I
find many a billion friends billion
friends is worth at least five or ten
billion dollars a billion dollars is
only a billion dollars and if I can
actually go make contact with a billion
people and get them to trade money with
me just five percent of those people
just five percent of those people gave
me a hundred dollars because I traded
some service that was worth a thousand
I'd be worth five billion dollars so you
see most people don't understand the
math the money money is not about
numbers money is about people need
motivation watch the top ten with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today this one from one of the best
Grant Cardone and my take on his top 50
rules of success enjoy
sale is made when when certainty that
your product or service will solve my
problem when the certainty goes way up
here you're going to make the sale when
the certainty drops okay which is uh I
don't know if I have a job I don't know
if I have money I don't know if my
company's going to make it I don't know
what's going to happen I don't know if
I'm going to get sick there's so many
there's so much uncertainty now that
that the consumer no longer believes in
themselves for their company so the
salesperson or the company today has to
reinsure has to ensure not just reinsure
but Ensure
the certainty of the consumer
um and and you you have to be skilled
now this isn't going to be just about
creating a landing page and an offer
unless you're selling masks we buy real
estate the cash flows so some of what
people want to show me here I'm like is
there any cash flow I'm always buying
cash online so I'm not buying
possibility I'm not buying
okay we're gonna speculate make a bunch
of money here does it cash flow next
month
because I want cash flow cash flow is
the Holy Grail of a business it's it's
why people the great Real Estate
Investors are even the great stock
investors or company investors typically
invest in cash flow companies Warren
Buffett is famous for everything cash
flows I've noticed in the parcel so
you've talked a lot about discipline
with money and how key this has been I
mean can you talk to me more about that
because obviously you know what you've
needed to pay to have success and and
Financial Freedom because I I guess
everyone will see the wealth and the
spending but what price have you needed
to pay yeah look the price I had to pay
was uh not to be broken not to make
excuses and not to feel sorry for myself
and not to be a victim
you know the fact is on this planet if
you don't have money you're in trouble
now I know some of your audience this
this is this message kind of just grinds
out the individual because you're
struggling with money and you're like oh
money's not all that I'm not talking
about watches and planes and and big
houses
you know I'm talking about having enough
money that you have confidence in your
ability to get up in the morning and say
hey I can take care of the people I love
so I'm not talking about all the extra
the flaunting stuff right
um talking about knowing within yourself
drop me off anywhere in the world
I just finished a project it's going to
be on TV in January
uh Discovery Channel says hey we're
going to give you a hundred dollars
and drop you off anywhere in the country
can you turn it into a million dollars I
said where are we going where are we
going players
there we go man as long as I can speak
the language I can do it okay I have
confidence in myself and what is more
valuable than confidence there is no
watch
no watch no amount of money that is more
valuable than knowing hey drop me off
anywhere I can take care of myself and
my family take everything away from me
my name my money my brand my credit
and and leave me anywhere and I can take
care of my family and actually build
something that can take care of my
family even if I'm not around also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there let's talk about when you started
working for yourself because you know
most small businesses fail in the first
few years yeah one to three years yeah
that most don't make it yeah I mean
there's a lot a lot of different numbers
out there about that like 50 of all
businesses fail after about seven years
or two because they were failing in the
first six months okay what do you think
they did wrong they don't know how to
sell anything I mean you go to Harvard
Yale or MIT they're gonna if you do
studies oh the reason they were under
capitalized okay look this is completely
ridiculous what they're telling you okay
you don't you don't capitalize a
business and then run out of money
that's not how you do a business right
this is how Wall Street does it they rip
people off they basically go most most
companies developed by Wall Street are
in Silicon Valley or complete rip-offs
of the investors you hear about the
Netflix that made it it might not still
make it it's still a negative cash flow
business because they don't know how to
sell their products fast enough in
quantities big enough and it prices high
enough to basically fund the future so
businesses fail for one reason and one
reason only because you can't sell your
products fast enough
in quantities great enough and at prices
High Enough
to sustain the business thus Harvard
says oh they ran out of capital yeah why
because they didn't sell their products
so if you can sell products fast enough
quantity is great enough Google Google
is a company you don't consider a sales
company Google
sells products in quantities that are
giant yeah yeah it profits margins that
are high enough when did you first start
uh on like the foray of Entrepreneurship
when did you stop working for somebody
moved on to your own thing what was that
was it uh real estate that kind of yeah
no so the the car dealer that I work for
for seven years fired me
um it was kind of a mutual firing thing
uh and and I went out and started I went
out and looked for another job
and I was either going to go sideways
meaning I was going to go horizontal in
my job or I was going to go up and and I
had two choices one was horizontal just
moved to another position in another
company or kind of kind of like what
we're going through right now pivot and
move up
rather than take a loss and go sideways
or down I decided to take a bigger
challenge something that was scarier
which was speaking uh working for a
training company I was 29 years old went
to work for this training company I did
that for two years
uh and then when that expired that came
to an end because of the company uh
and I went and started my own company
so everything I had done prior to that
point point the the selling the sales
the firings the you know losing
positions uh drug addiction that I had
for nine years in my teenage years to uh
working for this company exhausting
myself working for a company that really
didn't have long-term plans was all
preparation
The Good the Bad and the Ugly of it was
preparation for me to start my my own
business when I was uh 30 31 years old
explain how you went from a Salesman who
was in it and hated it yeah to then you
know you moved on and became
self-employed and then you were speaking
about sales and you're like a sales
expert so that's what 20 years in
between or 10 years yeah no there was uh
there was maybe uh 25 by the time I'm 26
I'm the top one percent of all sales
people in the Auto industry I didn't
really know what that meant but but it
was important to me that I was very good
at what I was doing now now I was in I I
went from hating a job in car sales I
remember going out with this girl and
she said what are you doing I said I'm a
car salesman and she got that look on
her face like oh my God that's worse
than a man yeah you know I mean and and
and I had this terrible thing I'm like
okay I'm gonna get great at it I started
studying sales every day I started
recording interviews like literally
you'd come in to buy a car from me and
and I hired my mom my mom was 70 years
old to them and I hired my mom and I
said you sit over there and you take
notes really and watch her watch when I
lose her Watch What Happens and we're
gonna debrief at the end of the deal
and I'm gonna see what's working and
what's not I'm recording myself videoing
myself I'm using every little piece of
technology 30 years ago I can to find
out what am I doing right what am I
doing wrong and what I was doing I
didn't know it then but I was basically
codifying sales I was learning what does
it mean when I say I'm gonna think about
it when is that real when is it not what
does it mean when it says the price is
too high when's that real when it's not
and I started codifying and writing
taking notes keeping all this
information I didn't know this would
happen but five years later I'm out on
the road knocking on doors uh selling a
a new way to sell things what you want
is that in the hands of a person
whether you want to be the queen
the king the president
you want to be Boris
uh you want you want to pull off the
brexit exit you want to pull brexit back
in whatever you want to do in life man
whatever you're trying to trying to
convince people to do you want to raise
money for your charity I've raised over
115 million dollars for Charities I
didn't do that because I understood math
I did it because I understand people I
didn't scale the way I should have
because too often I was doing either the
same thing over and over and not getting
bigger
like today when we find something that
works we're like okay how do we connect
that the 10x rule changed my my life
people talk about they talk about online
about the 10x rule is a book that I
wrote it was the third book I wrote and
and people like that book is a game
changer that book's one of the best you
know best books they've ever written and
it's on a it's on the most top 10 most
inspirational books in the world but
that but that book was written for me
I was trying to figure out at 50 years
old how do I scale how do I actually go
from
in 2008 I think I had uh
uh 300 Apartments
well I had 160 Apartments when I was 35.
so
35 years old I had 160 Apartments when I
was uh 50 years old I only had
about 180 apart like I didn't have maybe
2 30 or something it wasn't that much
more
from uh 2008 to 2020 I went from 160
units or I guess I had
maybe 230 units at the time I'm at 7 700
I have more bake I have four times more
vacancies three times more vacancies
than I owned 12 years ago
because I learned how to scale this 10x
thing was about how do I take double
down no don't just double down how do I
take something that's working and don't
do something new take something that's
working
I think about Jeff Bezos right now
because I'm like he he went from hey I'm
gonna uh I'm gonna go from selling book
books on Amazon to selling everything on
Amazon scale
yeah so how do you do that you you you
study statistics and you double down
when you're winning people should be
looking where they go
they should be looking for opportunity
before anything else not money not where
the location of the office is they
should be looking for particularly the
talented people how big could I get with
this company and they could go further
with a company
in most cases than they can by
themselves if you're at home you're an
entrepreneur you're a small business
startup
you're not spending time and money
don't call yourself an entrepreneur
because by definition you're not
I'm going to be back here in November
and there's going to be people that will
not spend the money because they don't
have the money that's what they're
saying I don't have the money so I can't
spend it to come spend a couple days
with me there's so many ways to get the
money yeah exactly so so an entrepreneur
says Hey entrepreneur on entrepreneurs
by definition don't make excuses okay
you want to come to the growth
conference and figure out how to come I
know it's an excuse that I shouldn't say
to myself and like if you make excuses
that's one thing but don't be don't make
excuses and become a liar exactly you
know like be honest at least say look I
made an excuse I didn't come to the deal
didn't make it work don't don't be I
make excuses and I lie to myself right
so exactly um the entrepreneur needs to
be get brutally brutally honest with
themselves and with their family and get
participation from the family unit
handling kind of criticism and people
saying don't do that or you can't do
that because you know on any kind of
success Journey you do get a lot of that
what how did you kind of handle that
yeah you know in the beginning you're
not ready for it I was not ready for the
amount of
um
criticism you know first you're going to
be ignored
in the beginning you're just going to be
ignored nobody's going to even pay
attention to it you could be Jesus you
could walk on water and they're going to
ignore you nobody will even see Jay did
you see that did you take a selfie you
get it on Instagram if you didn't it
didn't happen so it doesn't matter like
you could literally save the world and
if nobody saw it they're going to ignore
you in the beginning then they're going
to reject you
third thing they're going to do is
they're going to criticize you and make
fun of you
but if you stay with it they're going to
adopt it okay I mean brilliant people
are adopted at the end if they just stay
with it the hate along the way is part
of the game for you to get past being
ignored and then rejected you will be
hated on
and once you start accumulating enough
success
uh we were we were uh I told my team
over here we got 155 employees I'm like
guys look
you have to be ready it's coming a
criticism the stuff online don't even
look at it it's all garbage
and if it affects you negatively
it's not about what they're saying it's
about what it does to you personally
I just know it's part of the game now in
the beginning I wasn't ready for it now
I understand Oh My Success is dependent
upon the hate and the criticism and the
rejection
you gotta have it it's part of the it's
part of the recipe of success
unfortunately
because people that quit are going to
hate you for not quitting
we're actually not talking about you
they're talking about themselves and
they're like he's wrong for having a
damn plane
because they quit on their play
everybody can have a plane the crazy
[ __ ] is everybody can have everything
they want because there's enough to go
around for everybody
so uh for every guy that doesn't have
what he wants there's somebody on this
planet that has the ocean front house
that goes on as many trips as they want
some guy that's got the 200 foot yacht
some guy they that funded a hospital
somewhere and put his name on it
and and
you know it's just crazy that that hate
always comes from the same place a
quitter haters actually on haters
they're quitters what are your best
three marketing tips
uh to number one is be everywhere all at
the same time
it's called omnipresence
so
omnipresence anything that is
omnipresence by the way has survived for
since the the beginning of man 300 000
years or whatever
whoever can be everywhere will be
assigned power
whether it's the queen or God or
Coca-Cola
whatever it can be everywhere will be
assigned power
and so omnipresence with marketing this
has really never been possible before
until the digital age the last six or
seven years
Facebook Instagram Snapchat YouTube
these things that based on the age of
this audience half of you probably don't
use
you know because you're like I don't
have time for that this well-dressed man
right here with the sweater and the
glasses over his nose and this man this
man this very aristocratic looking
gentlemen okay he are you on Facebook
sir
he's on Facebook that's unbelievable
Instagram
no YouTube
I mean you have a YouTube channel I
don't mean you watch my YouTube
you have your own YouTube channel
okay that's pretty good so but but but
you see like like you should the answer
to your question is be omnipresent two
use all channels all of them everything
I'm gonna use YouTube Snapchat LinkedIn
Twitter I'm going to use uh uh
newspapers
even though most people aren't reading
newspapers I'm going to use magazines
I'm going to use
that's that's marketing I'm going to use
Expo events like this
events like stages like this I'm going
to use telephone calls cold calling warm
calling
I'm going to use Billboards if you go to
Miami right now you'll see 28 massive
Billboards throughout Miami a million
dollars worth of marketing material
where I'm introducing where I live
the business owners to my name
so I would use every
um marketing means possible lastly the
number three thing is I would have your
marketing budget
be
have a target of your last year's income
I would spend more money on marketing
than I do people and I would spend more
money on people than than I could even
imagine I would just spend more money
there was this book written called The
Millionaire Next Door it was a big
sensation too A lot of people read this
book it was a super super hit big hit
book okay and when I read the book I was
like I got something different from it
than what other people got from it other
people were like okay I'm not I'm not
going to coffee shops anymore okay I'm
not gonna buy a brand new car anymore
what I got was I don't want to be The
Millionaire Next Door
that's what I got from the book so it's
all about your Viewpoint right when when
I finished reading the book I was like
okay I don't want to be a millionaire
and I'm definitely not going to take
advice from a millionaire because when
you get a million dollars if you if you
came from if you came up the way you and
I did and you had nothing I give you a
million dollars and you're gonna think
dude
oh my God I got a million dollars your
mom's gonna kiss you oh God I always
knew you could make it right uh and and
then and then and then you're gonna wake
up the next morning and say dude I don't
want to lose this money
you go into conservation into defense
you start playing defense
I was with Mike Tyson I did Mike Tyson's
podcast the the boxer right well in 19
years old Mike was a champion of the
world yeah
when Mike got in a ring man in in when
he was at his perfection
and he didn't hit you once he hit you
and he kept hitting you until you went
down there was attack attack attack
attack
attacking two you couldn't get up two
you're like you're just gonna even if
the body can get up you're like I don't
want to get up now because I can't win
this and that is the way people should
be attacking life right when Mike
started getting data I even told him
this I said dude when you went to the
therapist when you started therapy is
when you started having problems Grant
you're right grant crane you're right
when you stop seeing the therapist you
got better because the therapist puts
you on defense what are you doing you're
still going on defense you started
looking at where you made your mistakes
as opposed to saying hey dude what
worked let's repeat it let's don't do
destructive stuff yeah let's get rid of
whatever's driving the destructive
Behavior right but the with money man
with money what you want to do is you
want to double down
this is why the casinos never never you
know get broke because nobody bets
enough in the casinos if all the whales
showed up in Macau yeah or in in right
here in London or or in Vegas and all
the whales showed up at one weekend and
said hey we're going to break the bank
and we're going to all push in hard they
could take down the casino but because
all the little guys go to the bank they
they lose five they lose five they lose
five they win 15 they say I'm out of
here yeah okay if they break even they
think they had a big night people are
like a bigger is not better and you know
I'm better off by myself you are not
better off by yourself it is absolutely
impossible to live on planet Earth as
one person try to communicate the seven
billion and think you're going to stay
in the game you're not it's impossible
so you solopreneurs out there your
business model that you created is
already broken thinking I'm going to be
by myself and do it by myself and the
proof is in the pudding because there's
28 million small businesses in America
22 million of them uh Break Even or lose
money those 22 million all have one
thing in common
no employees no support I made the
mistake in my life of studying people
that appeared to be successful
a lot of people are like that
they appeared to be successful you know
today today in the the the the times
that we live in you know you can go on
Instagram it looks like looks like
everybody owns a Ferrari everybody has a
Rolls-Royce everybody looks like they're
having the best day of their life that's
not studying that's watching I want to
study people
or even even at conferences you can go
to a conference and watch somebody on
stage and he couldn't he he or she could
present to like they're so successful
but if you really get behind the scenes
you'll find out there is no success
there it's just a lot of talking
and so I was just strongly suggest to
people this
a handful of people and make sure those
people are actually doing not just
saying
you know that they're they're not
talking about success they're actually
doing success every day how would you
know what they're doing well you should
you would you would see it in their
statistics right like there's some
things you can't fake yeah you can't
fake somebody
uh we're buying 250 million dollars
worth of real estate this month with my
money
how hard to fake that okay it's a great
Instagram post by the way but you can't
fake it there's going to be a loan
there's going to be a building there's
going to be you know acres and acres of
land there's going to be people living
there like you just can't fake it so
there's a lot of things you can fake you
can make a nice little quote put it on
Instagram
people look at it like that's the truth
you know and and uh the public is is
confused with a lot of what appears to
be the truth that's not yeah and so I
would just tell people
um
study people
that have success that are doing it now
also the second thing I would say is
make sure that where you're getting your
advice from them lines up with where you
need advice
right so Warren Buffett you know Warren
Buffett he he's at the he's at the he's
at the tail
um he he's at the tail of his of his
he's probably here right so
here he was doing different things than
he's doing here he he talks about
investing in stocks but he actually
doesn't do it he doesn't buy stocks he
buys companies yeah uh so you gotta you
got to listen to people Steve Jobs right
here was one of the most aggressive
business people that this planet's ever
seen I mean he was Barbarian aggressive
so was Bill Gates but if you talk to
Bill Gates today Bill and Steve Steve's
not alive obviously but Bill Gates today
saying dude I'm giving all my money away
money doesn't matter that's not what he
was saying right here right now in 2020
here we are in April right we have this
Kavita thing happen and we have massive
unemployment worldwide literally a
worldwide recession if not a depression
about
information right now this is not the
time for me to go try something new
this is the time for me to double down
on what's working how to help people
right now how do I scale Cardone
University how do I help customers I
need to actually contract a second
so that I could pull the forces back
and prepare for another assault yeah you
can't just go run out like a lot of
people think 10x is oh all the time
you're 10x sometimes 10x means I got to
contract again get rid of some stuff so
I can double down or 10x on the things
that are working so I can move again and
set up that other company that I want uh
uh to to for instance the real estate I
can't go expand my real estate portfolio
in this environment today
not because I don't want to but because
the markets have seized up
I need a second
I need a second for things to relieve
themselves uh to to
in order to go back and go from 7 000
units to 14 000 units I hope he's been a
big part of your career in invested in
property well you know can you just give
us insight into do you still think that
that's a good investment for people
because I know you've been on record as
saying you know it's not a good idea to
to own your own house that kind of thing
what where you know what what are your
views on the current uh property market
so so the issue the issue for property
again I love real estate you know we buy
real estate every day every day I'm
trying to buy some real estate but the
problem is priorities people
God gets out of school
gets married husband and wife oh we got
to buy a house that is the wrong first
thing to do like why are you buying a
house
we need a place to live that's an
investment a house is not an investment
a business is an investment
uh going to dinner with a client that is
an investment
going on a trip to meet with other great
people that could become investors or
customers that's an investment buying a
house is a place to live
and the banks the banks years ago the
banks convinced the public that
uh a house is an investment a house is
not an investment
so why are people notice how many of
your friends bought a house but they
haven't invested money in their in their
in their business
they bought a house but they didn't
invest money in making themselves better
dude I am the house
It's the Grant Cardone house
okay where I live does it really matter
to me it could be the Ritz hotel it
could be the Four Seasons it could be
the Marriott
it could be your house I could go bunk
up at your place
the Investments people should be making
is number one in myself number two is in
my business and the third thing they
should buy once they got the first two
handled everybody should start trying to
invest in real assets or real estate
that pays them I'm not talking about a
house I'm talking about buy a buy a
piece of real estate that other people
rent
from you so that you get cash flow how
do you build a business with a strong
base of operations you talk a lot about
sales and marketing but how how do we do
it that that sales and marketing go into
a strong base of operations and process
how do you go what advice would you give
an entrepreneur to build that strong you
need a strong culture you have to have a
strong culture and the culture starts
with the leadership right so if
I'm trying to teach and this is what
happens in big companies and causes big
companies to fail is the CEO often is
not really connected to what's happening
on the ground and
um it's one of the reasons we've been so
successful in America crowdfunding yes
against conglomerates culture is the
leadership calls out the people around
them it keeps everybody sharp exactly or
you have a culture where everybody's
asleep exactly you have culture either
way it's like what culture do you want
do you want Warriors and Fighters and
acquirers and people that are hungry and
never satisfied or do you have a a
culture we just left the meeting and
they're like we got problems here
people are satisfied
or and not working hard enough there's a
handful of people that are extremely
aggressive here but for the most part
the the woman told me most people are
just making excuses not going to the
next level not taking the action
saying this or that about this or that
that's the reason why this or that is
this this or that right and and so you
got to build a culture of no excuses
means you got to bring hire people and
get rid of people
we met with some real estate agents
yesterday they hired a thousand sales
people for this project they're doing 10
10 billion dollars worth of real estate
to sell they want me to sell it all
I said yeah I can do that so I'm sorry
and and
um
a thousand sales people now they're down
to a couple hundred I said dude you
don't have call you you you you have to
get a strong culture
he's like we don't have any culture I
said oh yeah you do you you onboard
people and then you don't train them and
educate them and and make sure that
they're excited and keep with them you
can't go to an event for three days get
excited and think it's going to last
three weeks later it's not that's got to
be instilled into the culture
you know you look around these buildings
the way these buildings there's
reinforced steel there's concrete
there's glass there's blue like some
something's holding that thing together
the birds where I'm staying it's holding
it together long after it's built and
that that's what has to happen with
management and ownership can you walk
through the 10x rule like I know you
start a touchdown points but like just
high level just because some people may
not know like you're known as the 10x
guy but what is a 10x rule at its core
yeah well the 10x rule first of all the
10x rule is not an idea it's a way of
life
and and people that go 10x are Massive
Action people
and and the premise of the book is
there's four levels of action there's
see you don't do anything
you retreat
you do average
or you go 10x
now the first three the first three we
everybody knows somebody that does
nothing that you call them lazy actually
it's impossible to do nothing but but
just for conversation we'll say a person
does nothing we know that's not going to
work going retreating if you Retreat
your entire lifetime it's going to be
very painful retreating by the way is
actually
takes more energy
than just normal activity just the guys
that get up every day and go to work
every day going backwards making a
decision to do something and not doing
it is it's very painful a lot of wear
and tear going backwards
the third the third one
is the most damaging of all three which
is normal levels of activity the
acceptable
the average the the middle class the
norm
because you get lost these people get
lost they work every day they show up
every day they dig ditches every day
they do a good job every day they're
loyal every day
but they never get rewarded ever
uh number three is the story of my whole
life that's where I operated the most of
my life most people normal levels of
activity maybe just above normal just
enough to shine a little bit but dude I
never went for it
and and and so the 10x rule is like okay
how do I really take some risk here
how do I really put myself out there
um so the middle class of America is
basically laid up on number three
being convinced to go to number two
and then ended up with nothing basically
they'll end up with number one
and how do you suggest somebody takes
that move from three to four yeah so you
what you would what you would do is you
you need to understand that number three
is is the the biggest disaster that we
have it's where
all wealth is created on the backs of
number three
uh the the the wealthy the wealthy
and this will happen again we'll come
out of this this virus thing people will
go back to consuming again
and they'll go back to debt they'll go
back to borrowing money to buy things
they don't even need to impress people
they don't even know
because they're unsure about who they
are and where they're going
and so the the middle the middle of the
the spine of America the spine the
middle class of India when it develops
the middle class of China will fund the
wealthy
and because they do the normal things
the wealthy do not do normal things they
do completely
you know they they do they don't they
don't save money wealthy people don't
save money they invest money
wealthy people don't spend time or
manage time they they they take money
that's useless they know it's useless
and they buy
um again a thousand employees
and then everybody's like well you know
that guy never works he hired 1 000
people to do work this is an old Story
by the way you can go back to the King
Tut
okay I mean it's it's it's not a new
story it's like how do you get wealthy
well you commit to Massive Action how do
you do Massive Action
you only have 40 hours a week or 80 or
100.
uh Elon Musk says hey man 100 hours he
works 100 hours a week he he does the
video about the hundred hours he's like
look if I do 100 and you do 40 I win
he's a smart dude too by the way real
smart guy but he's nobody without the
risk without the big think and without
the Massive Action I spent five years in
college I went to college because I
wanted I thought the teachers were going
to teach me business
I love teachers okay teachers are great
people but you can't
no business
if you're in a classroom
it's just it's just not possible it's
like my economics
my economics teacher
uh there there's no way he could imagine
the the fuel bill on my plane it's just
not real you go to Lord Sugar and say
hey
how do you make sense of four Jets
why would you do that
why'd you buy that building right there
that's the information I want see but
see but most Us in this room we were
taught we had to go someplace and spend
four or five years there I'm not trying
to talk you out of school or university
but
the fact that it takes four years to get
out of University by itself is that is a
major problem
it's a major problem you know why the
four years I'm trading time for money
what do rich people do they trade money
for time I think the reason why people
drop their financial goals is because
the goals aren't big enough the the the
you know if if you make another 20
pounds or another 200 pounds or another
2 000 pounds it doesn't change your life
the goals are too small to start with
but if you go from a million to 100
million
all of a sudden Everything Changes you
go from 100 million to a billion yeah it
changes again dude it's like you go from
a billion to a 10 billion dollar company
yeah you're like okay wait a minute now
this is getting really serious if you're
a Money Motivated person yeah and I know
a lot of people aren't right A lot of
people just they've just given up on it
but why do they give one because well
they've given up on it so it doesn't
even matter because this entire
conversation is going to agitate them so
they're like I don't want to they
probably already tuned out they tuned
out already I mean I I didn't even get
them in time I should have told them
that they were going to tune out as soon
as I started talking about this but uh
and then we could have kept them yeah
um but if you haven't given up on the
money thing
then you you know you need to unders you
just need to do some math and and you
need to understand there's most the
people that you're listening to on
social media have given up on the money
yet yeah I know guys that have five
million dollars to have given up
now the trip I just we're on our 31st
day if you got five million dollars in a
bank account you cannot do the trip I
just did yeah okay you can't do the trip
you you don't have enough money to do
the trip man this is what the guy with
five million dollars he made five
million and quit yeah dude he was just
getting rolling he's like I don't need
anymore or his wife said we don't need
any more we're good let's just enjoy
life okay if you can enjoy life if it
five million dollars I'll guarantee you
50 you're going to have a hell of an
experience and you Bank 500 million and
you're gonna be like
it's getting real interesting not just
for yourself either because if you if
you got five million dollars you can
only take so many people with you
I I'm dragging people from all over the
all over the world with me man that
they're having experiences my daughters
are having experiences the nanny the
nanny who's doing the homeschooling
she's like oh my God this is the best 30
days of my life so when you get big
enough man when you get big enough you
can feed other families uh my dad died
when I was 10 years old I had an older
brother die when I was 20. by the time I
was 21 years old I was jaded
and just figured hey life is not going
to last very long
and somewhere from when before my dad
died to 21 years old in between there I
I thought I was going to be a
businessman one day I thought I was
going to be rich and successful
and James Bond
like I had all these ideas like when
you're a kid you have all these big
giant ideas and then Life Starts lost
dad lost brother
girlfriend lose her like I start
accumulating all these losses
start using drugs and alcohol start
using them every day start making bad
choices
25 years old I was broke
I was in debt
couldn't keep a relationship
had no no chance of being married or
having kids it was impossible
right it was just none of that was even
possible and and so so I started putting
my life back together but it's really
throughout the period from 25 to today
35 years now of me studying people that
are successful that has given me the
discipline
um
and the encouragement
along the way with some Milestones like
2008 when the economy collapsed that was
a that was a huge Awakening for me
uh getting married another monster
Awakening like it gave me another reason
to be have a purpose being a good role
model for my kids not just talking The
Talk
but being someone my kids could look up
to and said that
that's what success looks like
just having money just having a couple
million dollars if you're not making a
difference that's that that's one level
of success but for kids they they don't
care how much money you have my kids
don't
they they don't know that well what what
are
what is 167 million in cash look like in
an account I remember when a billionaire
showed me his cash account I was like
whoa
400 million dollars sitting in one
account I'm like my God I I literally
couldn't read the numbers my kids don't
even care
what my kids do care about what changes
children and what changes friends and
what changes your neighbor
is what they see you doing every day and
it just so happens it takes money
to do things
to fly across the world to make new
friends to create new Charities yeah you
know to Market to advertise Etc listen
to this I just I'm happy if I can take
care of my family that is selfish man
there's seven billion people in this
plate of Planet all different colors
different religions different ages
different problems they got places on
this planet where you can't get a you
can't get a glass you can't get a bottle
of water okay yeah but the guy that's in
the guy that's in London right now
thinking it gotten a flat pay for and I
got my two cars paid for and and I got
to good job and and yes yes me and my
wife are having some problems and the
kids smoking too much weed but you know
things are pretty good they're your
selfish bastard is what you are because
what you could be doing is is putting
another hour in early in the morning
another one at night taking more risk
growing something maybe even disrupting
your business in your industry build a
freaking Mega billion dollar business
yeah leave a legacy and put hope put
hospitals and schools in place and
really really make a difference look if
you're anything like me if you're one of
those people that's like hey I know and
you you know inside you you're gonna
make it one day that you're going to be
successful that you're gonna You're
Gonna Change the World look here's the
deal you will get your break okay you
just got to keep looking for it
sometimes it's so hard sometimes it's
like why is everybody else making moves
and I can't seem to find my break keep
looking for it all right keep looking
for it 30 years I wake up every morning
and say when am I going to get my break
okay when am I gonna get my break I see
other people making moves I'm like why
not me
that's happening to you don't get
frustrated don't give up hang in there
be persistent okay posting comments
below what break you looking for maybe I
can help you I know people I'd love to
help you one of the key I run a
marketing agency and a lot of my
customers say well I spent one dollar an
hour one pound and I only got one pound
back that's not success I need to spend
one pound and get six back what is
success in marketing number one is to
get known you shouldn't advertise first
you should get known first
so if I spend a dollar in marketing or
branding I don't need my dollar back
it's when you have a toilet you buy a
business and you get a hey we should put
a bathroom in our business how many of
you have a bathroom at your business
what's the ROI on that
there's no Roi on that
how many of you have an air conditioned
and a heater at your company
what's the ROI I mean does that get you
customers the air condition sends you
customers
some things you need to do because
you're in business
when did you start making sense of not
getting known there is nothing more
important than getting known
if you if you can't get known you can't
be in business if I don't know you I
will not do business with you if I don't
know this woman in red no matter what no
matter what no matter how good our
product is or what the price is I will
not do business with her regardless of
her ethics regardless of her honesty
regardless of her service if if we if we
don't know each other
we won't do business so I would spend
money on marketing before I'd spend it
on a toilet and air condition
and climb online stand is just through
there and to the left
I mean I would and I wouldn't expect I
wouldn't expect Mark to get me a lead I
would expect Mark to get me known
so that when people see my name they're
like I saw you do this thing with uh
with Grant Cardone when he came through
Wales that's how you lift your brand
it's just a smarter thing to do today so
that when you advertise with him and you
see the name now you're like oh I
remember you from this and that and they
put the pieces together people buy from
people they know
not from people they Trust
people do not buy the best product
either
people buy the best known product I love
that you can't tell me this is the best
coffee in the world
it's the best known coffee in the world
in my environment what happens in our
environment the reason we're growing is
because the code of ethics is we push
we don't want lazy around us we have a
lot of fun okay but when we're pushing
when we're pushing to get the deal done
and that starts with the leadership you
know here here I am four days we've been
here
I haven't been in the ocean yet you know
I haven't done the little things that go
across the ocean what are those called
uh jet skis the jet skis I haven't
jumped out of the plane even though
everybody's by the way I'd love to
skydive and I probably will come come
back in Scottdale but I haven't done
that because the Regents asking
something of me
right and if I'm like I'm too busy I'm
I'm riding camels today great experience
and I will have it but I have to set
priorities in my life uh the people
around me know that I'm going to take
the work before I'm going to take
the
Leisure yeah
uh granted so pay the price today right
they're the price and I can pay any
price tomorrow when I read these books
when in my 20s about successful people
they all they all owned real estate
all the successful people the the
Rockefellers the Oil Barons the railroad
guys they all ended up with real estate
car dealers car dealers don't make money
selling cars just so you know
car dealers make money
because they pay for their real estate
they rent it back to the store and they
end up with a facility that pays them
forever for for acres and Acres of real
estate just so you know every car dealer
in America gets Rich because of their
real estate not just because of their
parts the cars pay for the real estate
how many of you know a rich car dealer
okay McDonald's Ray Crock he he didn't
he didn't have the recipe he got control
of McDonald's because of real estate
Jeff Bezos today in every major city in
America right now is making real estate
place
so you're here because you already
understand that I understood it and I
started writing this down 20 units or
more talk about family life because
there's a bit I don't know what family
life family oh family yeah and um
there's a bit of a similarity between
yourself I mean a sentence I've got two
girls simmer age seven to ten so mine's
four and eight yeah okay and um my wife
um you know I met in a similar kind of
way you know how important is it you
know how important is it really
important man like you want you know no
matter what you're doing all day long on
the battlefield you want to come home
and
have you know have
mutual agreement on what's going on you
know I was there was four of us
yesterday we were at Starbucks or
something all four of us on Instagram
I'm like what is happening man we're not
even together anymore like four people
and everybody's looking at their own
different thing right I said something
nobody heard me I'm like what's going on
you don't want to be alone nobody wants
to be alone like like I mean maybe the
alone person wants to be alone but
success is better when you have somebody
to share with yeah you know when you're
successful and you have nobody to talk
to
hey I did this deal today
or you have or or worse
I don't know if this is worse or not but
it's similar is you don't have anybody
to tell yeah or you tell them
and they're like
we don't need all that that that's
another form of just isolation so you
know I I want to be on the I want to be
I want to have a team man I want to have
a team that's excited about what we're
doing and what we're accomplishing
um so man having family and having
people that that want to be on the same
and it's challenging too having other
people is challenging do you think
you're going to build
a brand because you create one great
video
it ain't gonna happen
so you need to create a lot of content
one one masterpiece
somebody somebody said the other day
they said I said you post that video
he's like it's not ready yet I said you
know what
a video post it's better than a video
that's perfect
post a video I don't need it to be
perfect nobody's asking for perfect okay
so this is what this is why TVs are
dying because a production on a TV show
takes so long then by the time the TV
show comes out everybody's lost interest
in it and they're they're doing
something else I mean we have viewership
on some of our channels whether it's
Instagram Facebook or YouTube or Twitter
or LinkedIn or SnapChat we have lead we
have viewership higher than some TV
channels in America to spent billions of
dollars while they're producing while
they're planning writing scripts we're
producing content you're just
just broadcasting you know we broadcast
okay and then and then so so you can't
one Masterpiece will not beat ten
thousand
uh pieces of content
so number one number two you you need to
you need to post frequently enough to
where you almost annoy your audience
okay you gotta you actually have to get
them through the annoying part like well
he posted too much he's posted too much
you need to post just a little bit more
so they're like oh wow this guy's I can
I can trust him now on the other on the
other side of the annoying
is I can trust him to post okay then the
third thing is you got to keep the
content entertaining and interesting
so you're not going to know how to do
that because you post once or twice and
and whatever you're doing this year
probably three or four or five years
from now you're going to look back and
say golly that was garbage it's going to
change I promise you so you know I've
posted I don't know 6 000 videos on
YouTube uh
um I don't know what I posted on
Instagram a bunch
a couple thousand posts on Instagram
um
you know I I don't know what I'm doing
most the time so just so everybody knows
there is no schedule there's no plan the
there's a commitment not a plan so the
commitment is hey we are going to tell
the world show the world what we're
doing now whether that's me on my jet or
me just buying a new car or me with my
family I've been ridiculed for all those
things he's using his kids for Instagram
I can't do my I didn't bring my kid to
the to the live show okay my kid walked
in while I was doing a show at nine
o'clock at night because she woke up I'm
not going to stop the show because my
kid walks in my life any more than I'ma
stop my life because my kid walks into
my life when you make the commitment
specific commitments write them down
what am I looking for this year I want
to lose weight how much weight this much
weight I want to make this much money
great how much money I want to bank this
much money I don't want to just make
money I know people that make a lot of
money end up with nothing I want to bank
this much money okay I want to have uh
some passive income coming in so I'm
gonna make this much money I'm gonna
keep this much money and I'm going to
invest this much money so I have passive
income be very specific when you write
your goals and targets down and don't
get lost in the mechanics while you're
writing them down I see a lot of people
they go to write their goals down and
they cut them back
by half and then a quarter and then a
tenth of what they were actually capable
of doing and then what happens is by
January 20th you wake up and they're
like dude I don't care about losing 13
pounds it doesn't change my life I don't
care about making another thousand bucks
it doesn't change my life I don't care
about these things and the reason the
Euphoria wears off is because the goal
is not big enough
set some big giant targets be willing to
be disappointed dejected be willing to
be uh come up short on your goals look
if I aim for the freaking Moon I might
end up with the Stars and I started
studying I started studying super
successful people and quit listening to
my uncle and quit listening to my my
friends and my family members and people
that had quit I quit listening to people
that had given up on the dream and
started
emulating people that had created the
dream
and then what happens is if you do that
like if a person if a person went back
to when I was 25 26 years old and did
exactly the same things I did they would
be exactly where I am our father if you
took everything away from me right now
the the things that are most valuable to
me you can't take away
so you take the plane away you take the
money away
take the real estate Port the portfolio
away
three years from now I'll be bigger than
I was because now I have courage
like if you guys can just find your
courage man
and that that's a muscle you got to go
build a muscle of Courage I have courage
nobody can take that away from you can't
steal it from me you can't beat it out
of me a true wealth on this planet is
helping other people
like if somebody else how many people
you think will hear in this interview
oh it will be thousands hundreds of
thousands okay so you know maybe if I
help maybe if I help 100 people out of a
hundred thousand
I'm like dude that's awesome
um you know I got family members who are
going to help 100 people in their whole
lifetime if I can help 100 people today
that'd be freaking crazy the other the
other 100
000 that didn't get the message whatever
man
you'll do whatever you want to do I
don't care like I don't even know you
right like like some guy was hating on
me that day I'm like bro I don't even
know you you know me I don't know you
okay understand the calculation that's a
problem because who knows me is more
important than who likes me
so yeah what what's my exit I don't know
that I have an exit I think the exit for
me is probably the same as everybody
else except I would like to live a
couple hundred years after I die
so my game today my game is not the
money game my game even though I played
the money game my game is
could could people actually could I help
people in the year 2150
yeah
that means I need to track down what I
did I need to uh put it in books
I've written 21 best-selling business
programs okay those programs should be
able to live like when we built
something when we build something we're
like can this live
50 or 60 years from now everything
everything should be everything should
be used right everything you're doing
should be used for something somebody's
gonna you gotta assume that you're gonna
be successful and if you're going to be
successful you should document it I
promise you you're going to look back
everybody in the room has done this God
I wish I had pictures from when I was
oh my God where's right yeah because you
were underestimating this is the 10x
rule you're underestimating your
potential to be super successful
then you're going to get there and say
damn what was I thinking you were
thinking you weren't going to be
successful and the truth is you are the
organism is going to be successful if
you don't quit if you refuse to quit and
you refuse to stay where you are those
two things you have to do refuse to quit
and refuse to stay where you are you
will get here the organism you as a 60
trillion cells will figure the way out
okay somehow if you don't quit and if
you refuse to not be satisfied with this
spot right here that you're at
the spot is you need an accountability
partner you need someone that you share
your goals with that will hold you
accountable a strong person somebody you
respect a mentor a guide someone that
you don't want to disappoint or let down
pick someone that you can have with you
on your side that you can share as often
as you need to
that your goals are this your actions
need to be that
and you did or didn't handle those
things okay and and have somebody in
your life where they'll hold your
account and say look come on man you're
better than this let's go do this I've
been using mentors my entire life a lot
of people don't know this at the age of
25 I had a mentor that met with me every
single day to check on me every day I
made commitments every day that person
met with me every day when I got into a
sales game I was 26 27 years old I met
with a guy every day to work with me on
my sales game every day he held me
accountable how many calls I made how
much training I did every day I have had
accountability coaches and mentors for
37 years when I was 30 years old I hated
the sales thing I hated like like I'm
doing this documentary right now in Tom
Hopkins I'm participating in it and he's
the guy that I studied and I studied uh
Brian Tracy and I studied all these guys
this was back when selling was like you
ask a question I answer it with a
question there was no transparency
you know you couldn't shop data anywhere
so everything was slick uh it was it was
criminal it was bordering on criminal
all the time like
uh
you know the the oh you I'm gonna put my
thumb inside my hand like this and I'm
gonna model you and match you and I
hated that like I hated the idea that I
had to become someone else every time
so basically what I did was
I tell the story all the time I was
selling fish when I was 19 years old I
mean if I if I'm if I'm selling fish I
just knock on your door and say I got
fish
that was my pitch
fish I caught the fish the fish are
fresh and before you say no look at the
fish yeah and I sold all my fish nice
and and so I learned how to do things
transparent in an industry
this is 30 30 years ago car dealers
didn't give you anything there was no
books there was no Google there was no
true car there was none of that right
right so I figured out how to be more
effective
selling with the truth honesty
transparency and authentic authenticity
and I I took that model and I went out
around the country and sold it to a
bunch of Car Dealers that were making
money deceiving people yeah
um
and and so that that was that that was a
big thing for me I know what I could do
now once you know what you can do then
you can do it a second time and and
that's why so many people can go
bankrupt and then come come right back
because they know now
the first time you do it you don't know
the second time you do it you're like I
think maybe the third and fourth time
you're like I know for sure I could do
this
so
that's why I say success is so important
success is my duty responsibility and
obligation to myself forget my family
for a second
I need success for me to feel good about
me so I can be good with my family
and I think a lot of people are trying
to do their life without having success
be part of it success is part of my
mental
like I think I think success actually is
the best medication for my mental health
you need things that pull you forward
once you have your coach once you have
your Big Dreams once you have your
schedule of exactly what you need to be
doing every day you need little things
that can pull you forward so you're
staying busy
busy
inaction in actions moving forward
things pulling me not pushing me things
that are pulling me forward okay I got a
date as soon as this is done today I
gotta go do this at 10 o'clock I get
done with that I got something at 11 30.
I need events pulling me forward that
could be an event unit you're going to
it could be a conference you're going to
it could be a meeting you're going to a
charity event have things that are
pulling you forward so that you're
accomplishing every day so that you're
proud of yourself respectful of yourself
you're loving yourself you're feeling
good about yourself sometimes dude
you're bad man when I look in this man's
eyes I'm like he's a bad dude sometimes
yeah could you make me the president of
the United States that's what I was over
there telling my wife I could get you in
Congress in a heartbeat you could get
Congress
Congressman Cardone there you go I like
the sound of that I need to dream big I
mean you cannot dream big enough
telling you you can't dream big enough
you can do more than you're doing
but you can't do more than you're doing
if you hang around with little thinkers
that could be your family members it
could be your friends could be people
you're going to school with and hanging
out with look there's a time and a place
to hang out with those people
can't pick your family I mean they say
you can't I wonder sometimes we don't
actually do the picking and just show up
there but I'll say that for another
conversation
but I do know once once you get with
your family the family that you picked
or they picked or however that might
work the selection process
wherever you went to school or go to
school or where you grew up or how you
grew up or religion you grew up in or
whether you're white or black or brown
male or female the question's always
going to be
what can you do
to do more with your life
to find your mission to find your
purpose
to find what you're great at to get
great at the things maybe that you're
not great at that you don't even like
doing number one think big
telling you you can do more and you will
do more than than you ever imagined if
you're ever successful in your life if
you ever hit it and you can you will
look back 10 15 20 years from now say
God what was I thinking
what was I thinking I promise you
you know it's like 80 pounds of weight
looks like a lot
when you're five or six years old later
it's pretty easy to pick that up
no matter what your frame is as long as
you do the work as long as you do the
work and show up in the gym one day
you'll be able to pick that barbell up
just like in life okay the things that
you think are impossible today the
things that you hate today the things
that you aren't good at the things that
you think are a waste of time the things
that make you angry
are all opportunities for you and the
first thing to becoming a millionaire a
multi-millionaire a Hector millionaire
or a billionaire
and I've spent time with enough
billionaires now
is they have made decisions to get their
money right okay whether they're going
public or selling a product scaling out
they had to make a decision to get the
money the finance model of their
household their business their product
or their IPO right right if they want to
go to the market and become a public
company so number one get your money
right
it's not about product knowledge first
it's not about sales knowledge first
it's not about sales process first it's
not about the follow-up first or writing
the customer up first it's not even
about attitude first it's about get your
financial mental get your money mental
right okay because if you're satisfied
if you're happy where you are
financially why would you sell anything
else look let's face it you're on
commission you get paid to sell things
you get paid to close deals you get paid
to follow up
only when it works okay number one get
your money mindset right anybody ever
surf you ever got covered up by wave yes
sir and it's throwing you down and
you're like and you're like I can't wait
to come up and as soon as you come up
you're like oh my God damn bam another
one hits you okay this is a tsunami
this tsunami
there is no place you can go and Escape
what's going on here you can go get
another job we have many people that
have tried that already some of you
might be thinking about it you're gonna
go some other place and you're going to
meet yourself again
and the tsunami will be wherever you go
there is no getting away from the
tsunami the only way out of this deal is
to say hey what do I have to sell today
okay so right now right now Dave did a
deal yesterday 9.95 what kind of
business was it Dave solar 60 months did
you ask the guy are you going to be in
business in 2025 yeah and what do you
say well he it was a three-year deal he
didn't like the price they said okay
let's do five let's do five years yeah
good okay so so you guys need to start
asking people first of all are you going
to be in business next year
you need to ask every person you need to
include a couple of words in in your
pitch right now okay
hey are you going bankrupt you need to
ask them are you going to go bankrupt
because they're thinking about it trust
me
they are thinking about I'm [ __ ]
gonna bust out here you need to bring it
up before they do this is straight out
of seller be sold initiate the objective
of the objection the unspoken objection
is what's going to kill your deals from
15 to 25 I was using drugs every day so
when I tell you
hey you can do anything
I was a
habitual daily drug user
overdosed three times
was brought back by people just
wandering into a room saying oh this
guy's in trouble
okay I was I don't know if I was trying
to kill myself at the time or I was just
didn't know what I was doing or stupid
or whatever like
I was a walking time bomb and I was not
to be trusted by my family by my friends
there was no one in my life between 15
and 25 that I could have a positive
influence on
I was a liability
to everyone in my life including my
family
and my friends and people I went to
school with and the places I worked at I
lost seven jobs in a row I was
unemployable
25 I went to a treatment center and said
I got to turn this around
I got to turn this around I cannot keep
using drugs they're bad for me I make
poor decisions when I'm using them I I
go out with the wrong people hang with
the wrong people end up in the wrong
fights I literally got like when you're
using drugs you're going to pick fights
You Can't Win not in a lifetime
you're going to get in the wrong cars
make the wrong decisions the wrong
purchases and you're going to miss a lot
of great opportunities so first thing is
you can't do great things
if you're incapable of making great
decisions and when you're under the
influence
and I don't want to preach to you I'm
just telling you what what advice I'd
give myself if I was on the comeback and
I was
15 years old being influenced by
everybody smoking the Kush
it's cool now
it's probably going to be legal
everywhere
going out drinking on the weekends
forgetting everything that you did
and just make it poor decisions so I
tell you hey you got you got to figure
out how how is that gonna somehow
Advance your life you're going to have
to make some hard choices if I'm a young
guy coming up young gal coming up how
can I pick great relationships when
everybody's under the influence
and again I don't mean to sound like a
like a a preacher or anything because
I'm definitely not that we're going to
have a great time this weekend I'm here
for a week we're going to have a lot of
fun but I couldn't do that if I was
still under the influence every day
first get rid of the little think
and the old ideas
and the middle class mentality
I'm gonna go to work I'm gonna save some
money I'm gonna put it in the bank I'm
gonna give it to the Man
yeah
they hate money
cash is
it's trash
is garbages pieces the garbage paper it
is only useful when it is used if you're
taking notes
they even teach you this in school this
should have been taught basic fifth
grade sixth grade not in not when in
high school or college
cash this is a piece of paper okay it is
a piece of paper it's worthless this is
a piece of paper this actually has more
value this piece of paper right here has
more value than this piece of paper
right here why because one person has
this piece of paper
2 000 people have this data
you understand this piece of paper right
here is useless though until it is used
you failed the business no Problem
you restart another business
so the way to play this is let's go
ahead and give your business the best
shot
you need training you're going to need
sales you're going to need phone skills
you're going to need follow-up otherwise
it's going to fail okay now watch we put
it on a credit card
if we put it on a credit card and you
fail
the bankruptcy court picks up the Visa
Mastercard of the American Express
the training contract you you you you
did with us lives on for your next
company
you guys understand that 100 of those
people will continue on in some other
business
a few of them will commit suicide
okay I'm done
but the rest of them are gonna be like I
gotta go do something and they are going
to restructure and start another company
Donald Trump has restructured casinos
man this is not a new thing like the big
boys restructure okay fail boom We
restructure we'll create something new I
still got a business okay you got to get
this guy to see this might fail but you
won't because you won't quit and you're
going to be over here in people's lives
you have distractions
and you have opportunities to go do
other stuff and look at other stuff
[Applause]
you know it's like in indecisive
indecisiveness is the weakness
as you wear so well and it's like look
you guys want to be you want to be
Hoodwinked by the covid you want to be
hijacked by the election you want to be
uh thrown off because of somebody's uh
comments about you
like the the universe will send you
endless
numbers of distractions
and and to to people that are fully
completely committed
they're like yeah I saw that happen yeah
I heard there was a car wreck over there
I got to send me something this morning
uh on from Fox News
about this guy that was arrested I'm
like why are you passing this on to me
and I said do not never pass on bad
information to me I don't need it I
don't want it I'm not interested in it
by the way you're better than that and
all the people you know the people you
know don't need that message
and at the same time by the way he sent
it to a friend of mine another friend of
mine my wife got it but nobody said stop
it hey guys hey guys
Papa's on a podcast sorry about that so
again you see that like like stop the
distraction stop the noise and and if
you don't say no to it it will continue
uh it will it will feed you to be
distracted and give you excuses to not
achieve the things that you you're
capable of learn to discipline yourself
if you got to go to the gym every day if
you hate going to the gym go to the gym
I don't like going to the gym but I'm
like I don't like my body hurt neither
sooner or later if you don't go to the
gym and work your body your body will it
will scream at you and it will hurt
lower back pains arms Shoulders Knees
you name it it's always going to hurt
and as long as it's hurting how can you
be fully available for the people around
you if your body's hurting two you got
to eat good foods okay got to make
decisions I ain't gonna eat junk
I'm not gonna eat the junk why why
because I'm saying no to junk if you can
start saying no to stuff
you can start saying yes to the good
things like my little girl right there
Sabrina say hi Sabrina
so pay the price today learn how to be
great at jobs you hate that's paying the
price get up early
go to bed early okay beat the Sun up
every morning it'll give you so much
confidence I'm paying the price when I
do that when I get up before the sun
gets up I'm paying the price when I go
to bed at nine o'clock and I'm not
watching TV and movies and just being
entertained and effective whatever's
coming my way I'm paying the price when
I don't waste the weekends the weekends
make you weak listen to me we cancer for
weak people
anything after 10 o'clock at night it's
for weak people
okay Saturday and Sunday staying up all
night weak people people are made weak
on the weekends pay the price okay give
up the weekends for the next five years
and Watch What Happens
five years man that's a lot of weekends
that's what is that 250 weekends is that
right yeah 250 weekends that means I'm
ahead of the people around me
I'm paying the price today
in hopes that I could pay any price in
the future follow up all the money is in
the follow-up it's not in the meet and
greet
it's not on the internet
it's in the follow-up you got to lead
somebody's interested how do I follow
them up and this is where the financial
thing comes back into play because the
follow-up is hard nobody wants to make
that second call much less the third one
or the fourth one of the fifth one do
you know that 25 of all sales people
make one phone call and quit 48 never
make two calls most never make the first
one it's crazy okay most of your sales
are made closed
between the fifth and the eighth call if
you're advertising on the internet
there's a good chance you have to call
people eight to eleven times just to get
them on the phone one time to qualify
them the first time to see if they're
even on the right product
so follow up the fortunes are in the
follow-up I just thought we'd take a
shot at one of these obnoxious
car videos because I know you guys love
automobiles probably more than I love
them as the private jet flies over us
this is a completely obnoxious just I'm
just gonna be completely transparent for
all the haters and the naysayers and the
all of you out there that hate on people
that are successful I thought I'd give
you something to hate on today because
content is King right
okay today we have my driver car my
driver card is what I roll in this is
the 2021 cullinan Rolls-Royce cullinan
454
000 of nothing but super swag obnoxious
thank you Bernie Marino
the next senator of Ohio by the way for
this complete obnoxious Beast of an
automobile okay this is not dog friendly
by the way you put a dog back here boom
that bad boy gonna be dead okay now to
my Tuesday car to my Tuesday car spider
458 458 that what is it 488 I ain't got
my numbers right but I got my money
right okay 488 low rider Tuesday get me
ready for hump day okay this thing is so
fast it is freaking unbelievable brings
me to my Wednesday car you know what
they say about Wednesdays this hump day
okay this is man this thing is nothing
but just freaking stupid luxury stupid
Bentley luxury 368 thousand dollars of
nothing but obnoxious to bring me to my
washer car okay 180 000 Mercedes V8
beautiful four-door sedan when those bad
boys are getting washed I take a day off
and drive in the little bits just to
keep me grateful about the bushes of
this crazy stuff I got up there okay
that brings me to my Friday car right do
I have a Friday car yeah this is my
Thursday car this is my Friday Rider
this is when I go DJ Khaled
[Music]
we the best
this is a phantom folks this is 650 000
and nothing but Beast obnoxious
freaking crazy black on black badge
but let me show you what I use on the
weekends
this
is the vehicle that does it all for me
okay what's up man my taco truck
Saturday Sundays is my taco truck this
is how I pay for all the obnoxious
selling [ __ ] on the weekends weekends
and for the week taco trucks for the
terrific go get you a damn taco truck so
you can buy all this obnoxious
[Music]
play
Italiano Fratello Familia
culinary cuisine
Grant Cardone is the king and I'm
obnoxious
when you lose a job and I've lost a
bunch of jobs when you lose a job
the the truth is people need to confront
get to full acceptance that
and understand that once you lose a job
you you act you might not be an engineer
or an accountant anymore but you have a
new job immediately yeah and the new job
is to get a job right and and when that
guy heard those videos I get he he
watched three of the 12 videos and he
basically I showed him hey look you're
not out of work your new work is to get
a job and you need to go get a job now
you can go get an unemployment check if
you want to but sooner or later you're
gonna have to confront the Beast and the
Beast is
uh I I have this gorilla under my back
wall it reminds me confront the Beast
bro
okay you got to confront the biggest the
biggest uh beast in the jungle and and
I'm the enemy
in my life I am the biggest problem I
have and so uh when you lose a job first
thing you got to confront is you
and say wait a minute am I out of work
oh no I just lost my title as engineer
my new job is to get a job
and commit to going to get that job
and because people it's going to be
easier to get a job this week than it
will be 26 weeks from now I promise you
because 26 weeks from now you're going
to have 25 million people running back
to the job market
you want to go look when they're not
looking for someone who is just starting
out yeah yeah how do they how do they
get themselves motivated at the
beginning well you got to show up I mean
you know in the beginning I just had to
show up even when I didn't have faith I
had to show up this morning I didn't
want to come to work today you didn't no
woke up I'm like man that's comforting
to me that there are days that you don't
Sabrina's laying next to me and she's
like I don't want to do drama class and
I'm playing games with her and we're
making up words everything that starts
with an S and I'm like man I'd just like
to stay here and just hang out with her
not even have her go to school today and
we'll play fit go fish for a little
while and then I you know I'm like okay
put your feet on the floor dude go take
the shower go do the deal dude show up
even if your eyes are bleeding even if
you don't know what to do keep it simple
show up
okay show up something will happen and
just do the simple things and for me the
simple things are always this call a
customer okay call somebody you want to
be a customer
call somebody you need to meet call me
call somebody that will support you I
walked into Martin Luther I was telling
Kevin I said God damn this beautiful
beautiful how many people is this seat
about thirty thousand twenty eight
twenty nine thousand I'm like yeah but
y'all never had that many people here
yeah
and they said yeah Joel Osteen was here
Joel Osteen had 28 000 people I said
I'll take the whole place Joel can do it
I can do it
right we were there five minutes I said
I'll take the place and they're like
when do you want it let me see if it's
available I said I guarantee it's
available and they're like how do you
know that you don't know our schedule I
said I guarantee you I guarantee you
it's available when I want it and
um when do you want it Super Bowl
weekend
they're like yeah it is available
because nobody would do an event on
Super Bowl weekend
now if you can understand why I did that
event because my entire staff including
Jared right here everyone
involved in this event said do not do
Super Bowl weekend why would I do Super
Bowl weekend I'm the only person other
than the Super Bowl doing an event
that weekend there's nobody else doing
an event everybody was worried about the
Super Bowl dude I just took out the
Super Bowl took out everybody it got rid
of everybody number one number two if I
pull it off
if I pull it off my brand will be lifted
up into the heavens
as something mystical yes okay amen so
so sometimes sometimes you don't do
things we made less money on that event
with 35 000 people than an event with
ten thousand but the brand lift was so
unbelievable okay like
the goal was hey Jared and every day
Jared and I were talking
hey Jared if we can pull this off it
wasn't about the money it was we pulled
this off dude it's a game changer for
the brand okay uh number one nobody's
ever done this 35 000 people Super Bowl
weekend the story is unbelievable we we
will pull it off ourselves and and and
every time somebody does an event after
this it'll be like Tony does an event
with 30 000 people yeah but Cardone did
35 000. yes yes you understand so I I'm
you want you want to pick up you want to
pick up residual from other people you
want to pick up reminders okay if you
could figure out how to use your
competition if they're competition or
collaborate with them either way you you
want to have their efforts reminding the
public
the similar of yeah but free advertising
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one-on-one I did
recently with Grant check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created and best
Elon Musk is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses